if there's been one predictable thing
about 2020 it's been
unpredictability especially in the movie
business the next few months will bring
us a plethora of new flicks that will
either get extremely limited theatrical
releases
or forego the multiplex altogether to
focus on home release
fans of the 1989 classic bill and ted's
excellent adventure and its 1991 sequel
bill and ted's bogus journey have been
pining for a third movie for decades and
they're now getting their wish
bill and ted face the music will return
to the now middle-aged heroes as they
grapple with their failure
to come up with the world-changing music
they were supposedly destined to write
bill we've spent our whole life trying
to write the song that will unite the
world
why can't we just go to the future when
we have written it
stars kiana reeves and alex winter are
both back on board and the stellar
supporting cast includes samara weaving
bridget lundy payne kristen schall and
william sadler reprising his role as
death from the second film
bill and ted face the music was
originally slated for theatrical release
on august 21st but it will now release
to a very limited number of theaters on
august 28th and simultaneously on video
on demand platforms
disney's live action mulan remake
endured multiple delays before the
studio settled on using its streaming
service disney plus to bring the 200
million dollar picture into american
homes
while the film will still receive a
traditional release in overseas markets
where that's possible
stateside viewers who are subscribed to
disney plus will be able to view the
flick at home on september 4th for a
premium 29.99 fee they will then have
access to it permanently
as long as they remain subscribers
disney was just pushing out its massive
marketing campaign for mulan when covet
19 threw a wrench into its plans
while the mouse house insists that this
is a one-time deal and is not indicative
of a potential new release strategy for
future titles
industry analysts will be watching the
film's performance very very carefully
mulan stars liu ife in the title role
with a supporting cast that includes
donnie yen
jet li rosalind chow and jason scott lee
i'm thinking of ending things adapted
from ian reed's 2016 novel of the same
name as the netflix original and it's
the first live-action film from
idiosyncratic filmmaker charlie kaufman
in over a decade
the movie is ostensibly the story of a
man named jake bringing his girlfriend
to his childhood home to meet his
parents
where it goes from there we can't be
certain but knowing kaufman's style
we're pretty sure that things will not
be what they seem and we'll be left
wondering what the heck we just watched
starring jesse plemons jesse buckley
david thulas and tony collatte i'm
thinking of ending things hits netflix
on september 4th
lion gate's supernatural horror film
antebellum was slated for release in
april of 2020 before being pushed back
to august
and finally secured a video on demand
release for september the film stars
janelle monae as veronica henley an
author who inexplicably finds herself
transported to the mid-1800s
antebellum is the debut feature from
short film and video directors gerard
bush and christopher renz
in addition to monet it stars eric lang
jenna malone keirsey clemens and jack
houston
look for it on all of your favorite
video on demand platforms beginning on
september 18th
take henry cavill as sherlock holmes add
in millie bobby brown and sherlock's
little sister and you've got enola homes
based on the edgar award winning book
series by nancy springer
the british mystery film was scripted by
jack thorne the writer behind the bbc
miniseries his dark materials and
directed by harry bradbeer who was at
the helm of the widely acclaimed second
season of fleabag
originally pegged for a theatrical
release the film's stateside
distribution rights were acquired by
netflix in april of 2020.
it will hit the streamer on september
23rd although the film was originally
intended for theaters netflix scooped up
writer director aaron sorkin's
historical drama the trial of the
chicago 7 due to the coronavirus
pandemic
the film focuses on the court
proceedings of seven individuals charged
with various crimes during the period of
civil unrest which accompanied the 1968
democratic national convention
you can expect plenty of sorkin's
characteristic rapid-fire dialogue
delivered by a cast of consummate
professionals including joseph
gordon-levitt eddie redmayne yaya abdul
mateen ii
mark ryland sasha baron cohen and jeremy
strong
it was of the utmost importance to the
filmmakers that the politically charged
film get the widest possible audience
ahead of the 2020 presidential election
which led to the deal with netflix the
trial of the chicago 7 will make it onto
the streamer in just the nick of time
it's expected to drop on october 16th
the tale of a homeschooled wheelchair
using teenager who begins to suspect
that her mother is harboring a dark
secret
ron was intended to make its theatrical
debut in advance of mother's day weekend
in 2020
alas it was not to be but the thriller
will soon be available on hulu hopefully
in time for halloween
writer director anish shaganti is
responsible for the 2018 screen centric
thriller searching
and star sarah paulson knows a thing or
two about bringing the scares
thanks to roles on american horror story
and the upcoming netflix series ratchet
in announcing the move to hulu shiganti
observed the film was about a girl who's
been quarantined at home her whole life
watching it the same way should be a
fitting experience in 2020. the film's
streaming date has yet to be announced
coming from director shauna festy run
sweetheart run centers on a young woman
named sherry who agrees to a blind date
with a guy named ethan
when sherry realizes that ethan has
sinister intentions she's forced to try
to make her way home on foot through the
dark streets of la with her date close
behind
starring ella belinska and pilu aspec
the impressive supporting cast includes
the likes of betsy brandt amilamine and
clark gregg
stateside rights to the film were
acquired by amazon in may but the
streamer has not yet announced the
release date
the 1877 novel black beauty his grooms
and companions the autobiography of a
horse by anna sewell
has been adapted for film many times but
the tale of a young girl coping with the
loss of her parents by bonding with the
titular horse is a timeless one
and the latest update on the classic
story will arrive packed with talent
the cast includes mackenzie foy in the
lead role of joe along with claire
forlani and
ian glenn and as black beauty's inner
voice kate winslet
originally slated for a theatrical
release the family film was acquired by
disney to bolster the library
of disney plus the company has yet to
announce a release date but we expect to
see black beauty hit the streamer before
the end of the year
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite upcoming movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one